What kind of scene needs to
be shot 20 different ways?
A big action setpiece? For "Thor: Love and
Thunder," it was something a little more
emotional. Join us as we figure out what scene
was so hard to get right, and chase down what else
wound up on the cutting room floor. Warning:
spoilers for "Thor: Love and Thunder" ahead.
Filmmaking can be complicated. Sometimes
what looks like a simple shot that lasts
just a few seconds can take days,
weeks, or months to get right.
Pickup shots will happen months or
weeks after a movie has wrapped, and
reshoots can sometimes take place weeks
after a movie is otherwise in the can.
Movies that are technically complicated and filled
with post-production work and CGI shots, like the
latest MCU entry "Thor: Love and Thunder," are
sometimes broken down into hundreds upon hundreds
of different shots. There's a reason it takes
months for some films to make it to theaters.
"It's been an absolute disaster, but
that's just the way it is on my films."
Between the retakes, rewritten scenes,
bits that end up on the cutting room floor,
and the fact that sometimes
studios will demand reshoots,
there are occasionally whole storylines that
can end up being lost in the editing process.
In a recent interview with IndieWire,
actress Natalie Portman revealed that
director Taika Waititi shot
one particular moment in "Thor:
Love and Thunder" in 20 different ways.
Indiewire didn't say what scene it was,
possibly to avoid spoilers, but Portman
noted that it was very emotional, saying,
"The interesting thing was how
we had room to workshop them.
We filmed 20 different versions of [one key
scene]. There's a few pivotal emotional scenes,
but we did really, really different
things, many different times."
It's quite possible that she
was referring to one emotional
part that involves Portman's Jane Foster
and Chris Hemsworth's Thor breaking up.
"Quite a reunion, huh?"
Portman also described some scenes that were
deleted from the movie's final cut. The actress
revealed later in the interview that certain
scenes with Tessa Thompson's Valkyrie and Jane,
which help explain Jane and Valkyrie's
friendship after Jane picks up Thor's mantle,
weren't included. Portman said,
"There were whole sequences, planets,
characters, and worlds that didn't end
up in the movie that were hilarious and amazing
and [that] we spent a lot of time and energy on,
and certainly the entire crew
also designing and conceiving."
Seems like a director's cut may be in order.
While we don't know for certain just
how many scenes were cut from "Love and
Thunder," we do know that at one point,
there was a four-hour cut of the film.
Taika Waititi and Chris Hemsworth spoke about
the cut to Collider, where Waititi explained,
"It was about four hours. And a lot of time on
set. [...] in the moment, you're like, 'This is
the greatest thing that anyone's ever filmed in
the history of filming things.' And you get into
the edit. You're like, 'I still kind of like it.'
And then, after about six months of it being in
the movie, you realize it was fun on the day but
it doesn't have any business being in the movie."
What kinds of things could we expect
to see in a four-hour-long "Thor:
Love and Thunder?" According to Christian Bale
who plays Gorr the God Butcher, there were two
previous MCU actors who made appearances that
wound up getting cut. Bale told Prensaescenario,
"I got to work with Peter Dinklage. That's not
in the final film, but I got to work with him.
He's fantastic. I got to work with Jeff Goldblum.
He's not in the final film either. As you see,
a lot of stuff ends up on the cutting room floor
even though it is beautiful, brilliant stuff."
It's unclear what kind of interactions Eitri
and the Grandmaster would have had with Gorr,
but it's a good bet things wouldn't
have shaken out too well for them.
Thanks to a lawsuit currently in process, we
know actress Lena Headey had a role that was
ultimately cut, too. She's never appeared
in the MCU before, so it's unclear who she
would've played. For our money, she would've made
an exceptional Hera against Russell Crowe's Zeus.
One can only hope we'll see all of these
unseen cameos one day. It would make
for some great bonus content on Disney+.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.